hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about the amazing
avocado I love avocados I consume tons
of them and they're great for the
ketogenic diet because they're high in
fat very low in carb hardly any sugar at
all but check this out they have double
the potassium two bananas it's 800
milligrams per cup loaded with vitamin C
vitamin K vitamin E and it even has a
pre vitamin A carotenoids which
basically will also turn into retinol
which is an active form of vitamin A so
because it's a fad a vegetarian fat it
has the fat Seibel vitamins okay now
magnesium loaded with magnesium tons of
vitamin b5 which is good for the adrenal
glands for recovery for energy for
endurance but it's really good for the
cardiovascular system and even though it
has 10 times more Omega 6 versus Omega 3
it's still anti-inflammatory because let
it normally Omega 6 is anti-inflammatory
and Omega 3 is anti-inflammatory and
this is just kind of reverse it's loaded
with something called phytosterols which
is a different type of certain fats that
help with inflammation so it will help
with inflammation arthritis things like
that but what's interesting about the
avocado is it enhances the absorption of
the pre vitamin A even from other foods
so if you have carrots or other types of
like spinach or kale it's going to
increase the absorption because it's
mostly fat of those vital pre vitamin A
in addition to that it will help you
convert that carotenoid was just pre
vitamin A to retinol which is the active
form of vitamin A so for my
understanding the avocados are the only
vegetables that will enhance the
conversion of the pre-and to actual
vitamin A so that way you get to
division a good vision you have good
skin a good immune system things like
that so I highly recommend consuming a
lot more avocados in your diet and I'm
going to show you look just a quick
little clip of what I do when I actually
cut in
kado to maximize the nutrition okay so
now here's the thing most of the
nutrition is a great concentration of
nutrition is right behind this shell the
skin so what we want to do is we want to
make sure that we capture the nutrition
so you just cut it like this and then
what you do is you take the skin and you
peel it off like so okay
that's a little secret so then you could
basically now cut this and go ahead and
eat it but we want this part right here
and if you scoop it out it's not as good
as doing this so you want to peel it
right under peel the skin right off so
we just take this it's real simple just
peel this right off and then do it like
that all right all right have fun